hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
in diesem video zeige ich dir wie du
diesen spaß machen kannst der ist es war
komplett und auch wirklich super lecker
den könnt ihr für motiv torten benutzen
als dekoration und er ist gar nicht so
schwer in der herstellung ich zeige euch
jetzt schritt für schritt wie es
funktioniert der recht nicht so schwer
zuerst hatte ich mir überlegt diese
runden pralinen zu nehmen dieser
lindower aber die sind zu klein
also nehme ich jetzt hier die kuchen
reste und bin eigentlich ganz froh dass
wir sie nicht schon aufgegessen haben
ihr könnt zum beispiel auch einfach nur
den schmerz machen als cake pops
ja ich mache es nicht so viele so schön
zerbröseln und dann nehme ich gerne
rasch und bei dem ich jetzt einfach nur
so viel dass eine klebrige masse
entsteht
ich sag es schon wieder
ihr könnt auch eine größere schüssel
nehmen bevor sie gekleckert hat hat sie
doch eine große schüssel gerade jetzt
hier schön mit der garage verbinden ist
nämlich den großen eis funktioniere und
fülle den einmal flach damit die form
das jetzt hier schön zu einer kugel so
rund wie nur möglich
guckt mal wenn ich sehen irgendwas
reinlegt was unten eben auch schön rund
ist dann werden sie nicht flach unten
die kugeln sind schön hart und jetzt
nehme ich hier böten passte und von
damit ich das ganze hab ich schon
gemischt eins zu eins nicht zu dünn
denn ich will jetzt die kugel damit
einkleiden und der park wird es darüber
gezogen
am anfang etwas schwer ich wegen
entfalten als wirklich so versuchen so
faltenfrei wie möglich hinzukriegen
aber natürlich muss ich an der
unterseite die falten zusammenraffen und
dann zwiebel ich sie einfach weg und
versucht jetzt hier so glatt zu drücken
die kugel lege ich jetzt kurz zur seite
und mache jetzt noch mal die flügel wenn
ihr fondant und blüten passt er mischt
dann könnt ihr es auch wirklich viel
dünner ausrollen
das kommt durch die blüten passte gucke
ich mir kurz die flügel an
als oben so rund und dann hinten so ein
bisschen geschwungener ich muss ich
tatsächlich ja der york hat nicht
unrecht denn ich arbeite normalerweise
immer mit essbaren dingen in der küche
immer besitzt das einzige mal wo ich
wirklich zaubern muss denn ich brauche
jetzt trat damit ich diese runde
hinbekommen zahnstocher wird nämlich
alles kaputt machen erstmal halbieren
und dann mache ich hier so eine rundung
so dann mache ich das hier so und so hat
sowieso ein geschwungenes dreieck und
dann nehme ich jetzt kleber wieder den
essbaren es kommt hier oben an den rand
dann kommt hier da draht rein und wird
so eingewickelt so haben die das
bestimmt bei harry potter auch gemacht
also guckt auf jeden fall dass euer
draht whistler länger ist und hier schön
flach drücken von der größe ist gross
geht eigentlich nur weil da ist ja auch
klein und die flügel sind riesig und
jetzt würde ich aber noch
der hat ja auch so wieso federn dran
dass hier so bisschen einschneiden also
eindrücken nicht bis ganz hoch dass es
nicht so ganz zerbrechlich wird aber
schon filigran
ich kann so voll den film requisit
machen ich mag filmrequisiten den
goldenen spatz
[Musik]
und dann kann ich nämlich mit dem pinsel
den kleber hier aufzeichnen
[Musik]
ja ich kenne jetzt eher schlecht
sitzender ich muss er runter und mache
einfach über querstreifen also ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen da bin ich jetzt
nicht so genau
nur da gucke ich einfach dass es gut
aussieht dass man erkennt was es ist
aber ich mache jetzt nicht jeden
streifen so genau wie sich's gehört
das match der fliegt weg hat er kann gar
nicht fliegen
der hat keine flügel dass schnaps kam
jetzt mal den gold was machen wir jetzt
so was hat der jetzt spricht erst mal
beim schwatz die unterseite ein lasst es
trocknen und dann die oberseite und
natürlich auch die flügel bei den vögeln
auch erstmal die rückseite und nach der
trockenzeit dann die vorderseite und
solange freue mich jetzt auf also wir
[Musik]
jetzt wird im prinzip nur noch alles
zusammen gesetzt also hier habe ich die
flügel vom schmerz hier muss ich den
draht etwas kürzen und zwar schon so
bist du dieser bricht ja vielleicht noch
zu sagen hast oder wenn du was macht und
dann weißt du eigentlich dass es kaputt
geht oder man es trotzdem und st der
goldene spatz du musst jetzt
funktionieren da werde ich jetzt auch
einfach isomalt nehmen hier rein und
steckten das ganze ziemlich gerade rhein
sowie bei dem schmerz da hinten
wenn ihr es so macht dann kann es
nämlich wirklich runter krachen
[Musik]
und jetzt mache ich hier nur noch zwei
kugeln drauf das hat nämlich der schutz
da auch und dann ist es fertig dann kann
es angerichtet
[Musik]